will is with us in Maine hey will how
are you oh I'm alright Dave are you
better than I deserve what's up I'm
actually gonna be a new dad in December
yeah and I'm pretty worried right now
okay
why are you bro I'm just lost I've I
know kind of your plan by every month it
seems like I take a traction I end up
spending all the money for the emergency
fund on overdraft fee's I'm just I'm
kind of a mess mm-hmm okay what's your
household income between my two jobs
right around fifty thousand why would
you intentionally write something into
overdraft it's mostly just I don't even
know it's coming out and it comes out on
day when my check hasn't gone in yet and
then I get slapped $40 worth of
overdraft fees I got you what do you do
for a living I'm alcohol and drug
counselor hmm okay okay so you coach
people on changing negative behaviors so
they have a better life right it's
actually a blessing because you have the
skills yeah you intellectually grasp
what needs to happen because there's no
math here that's calculus the math that
we're dealing with is a sixth grade and
we know you graduated from that because
you wouldn't be counseling otherwise and
so you know this is not you know it's
it's it's addition and subtraction it's
just bothering to care to make the main
thing the main thing right and you know
in coaching people and I know in
coaching people that are even if they're
dealing with an addiction that they will
not change until they're in enough pain
and the pet that you know we always say
around here the pain of the same when
the same old same old because
so painful that it's more painful than
the pain of change then you'll do the
change but you won't do the change until
you've got some pain and you call me
because you got pain and that's really
great news so two pieces of great news
is one you're in pain two is you know
what to do about it right so you need a
progressive step-by-step system which is
what you give your clients here's what
you do today here's what you do tomorrow
here's what you do the next day you stay
dry you know one day at a time right and
so if I hired you and I said hey dude
you got a new baby coming in December
have I got a deal for you I'm gonna give
you $250,000 over the next year in cash
as a consulting fee if you will take
this family in August I mean and show
them how to get their financial act
together you could do it yeah you could
do it I mean it's you sit down and get
your dadgum checkbook balanced you'd
know exactly what was going on you'd get
online and you'd have everything you'd
be so freakin anal and be unbelievable
wouldn't you yeah you'd get paralysis of
the analysis for 250 grand so the
questions not if you know what to do the
question is just motivation to go do it
and hey there's nothing like a new baby
to wake a guy up you know right that's
just awesome that's just that's the
biggest student and honestly it's the
most noble motivation mankind has ever
had just about and to do something great
for the next generation and it's
grown-up time and so you and your wife
are gonna come home tonight you're gonna
turn off the television you're gonna
download the every dollar app and you're
gonna sit there on your computer and
you're gonna do your first budget it's
going to take you about 30 minutes
you're probably gonna have a good fight
as you're talking about money and you're
gonna try to blame each other for all
this crap and it's both of yous fault
it's not either one of his fault am i
right well that's okay but your moat
mostly means she's she's it to blame too
and she's pregnant so she's really
scared
yeah and fear makes everybody really
fight good you know you really fight a
lot when you're
right so you may have a good fight but
be ready for that just go honey we don't
need kill each other we got to kill this
problem we're gonna beat this problem up
we're gonna do this we're gonna stop the
misbehavior starting now ready set go
you get your every dollar budget out you
know and when you lay that out you're
gonna say we've got enough money coming
in to pay our bills and the first most
important thing we do is we eat the
second thing we do is we pay the lights
and the water so we've got a place you
know we pay we pay our rent or our
mortgage payment pay the car payment if
you've got one or car gasoline and so
we've got transportation food shelter
clothing this family goes on you can do
that in August domain on 50 grand it's
very possible some other people may not
get paid but we're not writing any more
checks ever again when there's no money
in the bank right if the money runs out
you just call somebody winning money
this month I can't pay you they'll be
shocked cuz nobody ever calls and tells
them that but you're gonna do something
about it you're gonna fix it you're
gonna turn this around how much debt
have you got about thirty five three
okay on what 15,000 made hundred on a
charge thirteen thousand on a student
loan fifty four is the credit card for
fifty three is a credit card and about
eight hundred on stupid phones well you
guys 31 years old I am 25 25 Wow you did
the stuff early okay good well yeah
that's normal use normal I mean you're
just you got normal bills and the normal
income but normal sucks yeah and we
don't be normal anymore we're gonna get
game on here we're gonna make every one
of these dollars behave put the whip and
the chair to it make it behave crack the
whip on it and we're gonna get really
organized and we're gonna get really
responsible and have you ever noticed
the people you're coaching with I've
noticed this that the people that make
the best and most permanent life change
they go really extreme for a little
while like over-the-top like when they
go sober they go so sober that they
think everybody's a drunk you know and
then they dial it back a little bit
and they get more reasonable after
they've but they had to go all in the
other way they had to let the pendulum
swing all the way the other way to to
make the to redo the grooves in their
brain you know what I'm talking about
and so that's what I want you guys to do
don't you become financial management
fanatics for a period of time and then
you'll lighten up I teach this stuff
every day my personal life is fairly
light my budget is there's not a lot to
it because I many bills I got a lot of
money so it's really easy to do my
budget but you know I don't I don't fret
and sit and worry about this stuff but
when we started dude I was so gaming I
was like a money Pharisee you know and
people still say people think I still am
but I'm not nearly as hardcore as I once
was so um that's what I want you to do
and I'm gonna send you a copy of the
book the Total Money Makeover to help
you get that going it's gonna show you
exactly what to do step by step by step
it's the baby steps on steroids
and you know just follow that plan if
you'll do exactly that plan you don't
need to fix my plan my plan is not
broken it works follow that plan exactly
like a pharisee like a rule keeping nerd
and you will see turnaround immediately
and you'll see big turnaround within a
year hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]